je vais vous dressez un résumé de la
situation clinique je pense que c'est ce
qui me demandait aujourd'hui je pourrais
avoir des remarques aussi sur
des les les évaluations les évolutions
en termes épidémiologique mais spf est
là et sur les contraintes
opérationnelles en termes de prise en
charge et traitement pour vous donner un
état des lieux du terrain
pour vous résumer rapidement la
situation clinique on a affaire à une
variole simienne qui jusqu'àlors n'avait
pas beaucoup dépassé les zones d'endémie
qui se présentait
dans le cadre de zoonoses
essentiellement avec une transmission
interhumaine peu fréquente qui touche
est essentiellement les chasseurs ou les
enfants qui étaient en contact avec les
animaux porteurs du virus
essentiellement les rongeurs et les
singes et qui
sur cette infection virale à virus à
gros virus à adn enveloppé qui est assez
résistant en milieu l'inerte provoqué
sur la phase
virer milk de d'invasion systémique des
signes généraux de type fièvre syndrome
pseudo grippal est ensuite envoyé
l'émergence de lésions cutanées ou
cutanées aux muqueuses
d'évolution mono synchrone c'est à dire
en une seule phase
de la maladie qui touche essentiellement
la peau avec des lésions qui durait ans
qui dure excusez-moi environ trois
semaines
avant de cicatriser
une fois que les croûtes tombe et
pouvant laisser des séquelles
cicatricielles is esthétique
le pronostic de cette maladie connue en
zone d'endémie est variable en fonction
des régions et des sous types viraux
sur les données qu'on a et on pense
qu'elles sont pas forcément très
précises en termes de dénominateurs par
rapport au nombre de patients touchés
par rapport au contexte de la zone
d'endémie il est
on considère que la mortalité est de
environ 30% pour le sous type viral
évoluant en zone d'afrique centrale et
de 10% en afrique de l'ouest aujourd'hui
le sous type viral qui s'est disséminé
en dehors de la zone d'endémie et celui
d'afrique de l'ouest qui a une mortalité
moins sévère
ça c'est le contexte aujourd'hui depuis
le début du mois de mai on a comme vous
le savez une
diffusion au delà de la zone d'endémie
c'est déjà arrivé la particularité c'est
ces modes de transmission et je je je
laisserais détaillé spf mais la
particularité c'est que ça va avoir un
impact sur la présentation clinique
aujourd'hui et c'est inédit on a une
transmission interhumaine assez
dynamique dans une communauté
particulière avec des modes de
transmission qui sont essentiellement
les rapports sexuels dans le cadre de
multi partenariat
et ça survient sur un terrain qui est
assez
systématique donc on retrouve des hommes
qui sont en général jeunes et qui ont
très peu de com en billy t on à des
patients qui sont séropositifs au vih
mais la plupart sont très bien contrôlés
ne présentent pas d'immunodépression
nous n'avons pas de forme grave mais
dans la population d'aujourd'hui
ce sont des patients qui ne présente pas
de facteur de risque de gravité de cette
maladie qui est essentiellement les
enfants les femmes enceintes et les
personnes immunodéprimées
la particularité
clinique de cette sortie de la maladie
de sa zone d'endémie il y est
probablement aux modes de transmission
puisqu'on a des lésions qui sont
essentiellement en tout cas dans un
premier temps
génitales ou perry génitales
et qui vont évoluer aussi
avec la même chronologie classiquement
mais on voit régulièrement des
évolutions qui sont atypiques avec des
récurrences proche du de la première
entre guillemets floraison c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression que cliniquement
vous avez plusieurs
éruption cutanée qui ne sont pas
décrites dans la maladie la sig de zones
d'endémie qui pourrait laisser envisager
une physiopathologie différentes ou deux
pour qu'autant ciel recontamination
par ailleurs par rapport à la
spécificité des modes de transmission on
a des cas plus fréquent de réussite et
de pharyngite qui probablement sont
liées au mode de transmission quand on
ignore aujourd'hui les séquelles
potentielles au niveau fonctionnel
aujourd'hui on a en france de ce qu'on
peut en voir sur les dénominateurs
est en tout cas de l'expérience de
bishai de la pitié on a à peu près la
même évaluation oui du malade c'est que
la gravité est faible mais autour d'eux
un panel de 500 patients diagnostiqués
pour mischa pitié on a plus de
vingt-cinq hospitalisation
ce n'est pas complètement négligeable
par contre il faut préciser que ce sont
des hospitalisations qui ne sont pas en
réanimation qui ne grève pas le
pronostic vital qui sont essentiellement
des atteintes oculaires des kératite des
atteintes rectal ou des surinfections
bactériennes qui est sur la zone
d'endémie la principale cause de gravité
voire de décès sur un accès aux soins
qui est limitée était un accès aux
antibiotiques qui est parfois restreint
voilà en gros pour la situation clinique
que je peux dresser aujourd'hui avant
les questions éventuelles
alors qu'il prend la suite sans santé
publique france vous avez un peu passé
on va passer un bien pour vous souhaitez
vous appuyez on le passe tout de suite
ou ici bouquet matin le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
je vais vous dresser un point de
situation épidémiologique
voilà quelques diapos juste parce que ça
passe mieux avec des figures donc
diapositives suivante s'il vous plaît
si
positive
donc peut-être un mot pour revenir sur
l' alerte initiale 1 qui date de mai
2000 22 l' alerte a été émise par les
autorités sanitaires de grande bretagne
par un système européen qui permet aux
états membres et à la grande bretagne
également d'échanger des messages
d'information sanitaires de manière
rapide et donc ce message a été reçu par
la dgs et santé publique france le
samedi 14 mai et faisait état de deux
cas confirmé chez une mère et un
nouveau-né
d'infection amont que monkey pox avec un
cas index qui était le conjoint et
surtout sans notion de voyage ni contact
avec des voyageurs
et ça c'était des kakis daté du 12 13
mai donc la date du 14 mai les anglais
rapporte aussi quatre cas confirmés chez
des hommes ayant des rapports sexuels
avec des hommes sans non plus notion de
voyage ni de contact avec des voyageurs
et donc c'était très fortement en faveur
d'une transmission autochtone sur le
territoire de grande bretagne
donc ce message a été bien reçu par nous
mêmes et nos collègues de la dgs nous
avons eu une première réunion de lundi
pour effectivement analyser ce signal
parce qu'ils étaient atypiques
les notifications précédentes
concernaient toutes des importations
avec des gens qui avaient voyagé en
afrique le portugal seconde herman a
aussi confirmé ses premiers cas au
départ il faisait état aussi de syndrome
infectieux similaire avec des lésions
cutanées chez des homosexuels masculins
sans diagnostic étiologique mais ils ont
recherché monkey pox suite à l' alerte
anglaise et donc nous avons mis en place
des loups 17 mai une surveillance
renforcée une surveillance renforcée en
fait ça veut dire qu'en plus de la
déclaration obligatoire pour tous les
orthodoxes virus de la variole nous
avons mis en place une définition de cas
spécifiques et une conduite à tenir qui
a été diffusé aux cliniciens qui déclare
ensuite ces cas et au laboratoire est le
premier cas français a été déclarée
après diagnostic au cnr le 19 mai il ya
positive suivante
et donc ça c'est la situation 4 juillet
tel que rapporté par l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé sur
la base des données remontées par les
pays et donc au 4 juillet plus de 6000
cas étaient recensés avec une très
grande majorité 4920 dans la région
europe de l' oms une diapositive
suivante
vous avez la même situation date du 7
juillet sur la base des données
colligées par le centre européen de
contrôle et prévention des maladies qui
vous qui fait état de l'inventaire du
nombre de cas en europe et vous voyez
que les pays il est principalement
concerné en date du 7 juillet sont
l'espagne l'allemagne la france le
portugal les pays-bas l'italie et la
belgique je ne cite que les pays qui ont
déclaré plus de 100k
diapositives suivante
vous avez ici la courbe épidémique sur
la base des mêmes données européennes
alors vous voyez qu'il ya une
progression régulière
il faut toutefois noter que ne pas se
fier à l'apparence de stabilisation
boîte de décroissance sur les dernières
semaines puisque nous avons des délais
de diagnostic en moyenne de 7 jours et
par ailleurs les pays peuvent avoir des
délais de notification à le céder ces
variables je reviendrai sur ce qui est
la situation française juste après
diapositives suivante
juste pour vous illustrer un peu les
différences de dynamique par pays vous
avez ressentent la courbe épidémique
française on va y revenir plus en
détails juste après et vous voyez que
les trois pays en eau sont l'angleterre
à gauche l'espagne au milieu et
l'allemagne à droite qui ont des
dynamiques un peu plus précoce qu'en
france et surtout beaucoup plus
importante
diapositives suivante
donc sur la base de nos données
nationales c'est le bilan que nous avons
arrêté hier 12 juillet à 14 heures ce
bilan sera mis en ligne après une autre
séance on avait recensé en france 900 12
cas confirmés dont 828 ont fait l'objet
d'une investigation par nos équipes et
celles des ars et ont été décrits au 11
juillet ce qu'on peut dire sur ces 15
c'est qu'ils ont en moyenne 36 ans d'âge
médian avec une vous voyez une
intervalle qui va de 19 à 84 ans pour
les calades ult on a aussi cinq adultes
féminin et deux cas pédiatriques
effectivement parmi les hommes dont
l'orientation sexuelle est connue 97 %
sont des hommes ayant des relations
sexuelles avec les hommes et 75 %
d'entre eux sont des dans un contexte de
multi partenariat c'est à dire avec au
moins deux partenaires rapportés dans
les trois semaines avant le début des
symptômes dans la plupart des cas ces
cas ne peuvent pas identifier la
personne qui les aurait contaminé
diapositives suivante
en termes de répartition géographique de
ces 8 124 cas décrit auront juillet vous
voyez que l'essentiel et et
diagnostiqués en région ile-de-france
517 sur ce bilan mais on voit une
augmentation régulière de cas déclarés
en région auvergne rhône-alpes paca
occitanie et nouvelle aquitaine sans
doute aussi à la faveur des migrations
estivales
diapositives suivante donc ça c'est la
courbe épidémique française encore une
fois j'insiste
les dernières semaines ne sont pas
consolidées en termes de données nous
avons aujourd'hui un des diagnostics
médian de six jours en france il a
beaucoup diminué j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas
c'est que l'épidémie est encore active
la date de début des signes du premier
cas c'était le 7 mai et le dernier cas
recensé dans ce bilan le 7 juillet
diapositives suivante en termes de
principaux signes rapporté
80 % déclarent des éruptions génitaux
annales 73% une éruption sur une autre
partie du corps 70% de la fièvre des
adénopathies ou des boîtes gorge 5% sont
immunodéprimés 200 soit 26% sont
séropositifs au vih
et pour les non porteurs du vih 403 soit
70% sont sous prête comme je les dis la
prophylaxie
pré-exposition pour le vih
le délai mais non diagnostiquées qu'il
est de 6 jours mais il a diminué il
était très jour en semaine 18 il est de
4 jours aujourd'hui donc ça montre bien
qu' aujourd'hui l'accès au test
est beaucoup plus fluide qu'au tout
début on a quelques hospitalisation
apporte effectivement comme le rappelait
professeur xavier lescure ce pour des
gestions de douleurs parfois intenses
quelques surinfections bactériennes des
mesures d'isolement parfois l'analyse
est en cours dont je n'ai pas de données
plus précises à ce stade mais nous
pourrons vous les communiquer
ultérieurement aucun décès n'a été
recensé dans les quatre ans et plus
et donc pour conclure avant de laisser
la parole à mon collègue françois beck
voilà les actions de santé publique
france aujourd'hui se décline sur
plusieurs axes surveillance
investigations c'est à la base est la
source des données que je vous ai montré
contribution à l'expertisé lien avec la
recherche
on a des relations quotidiennes au
niveau national avec les cliniciens avec
des équipes de recherche notamment des
modélisateurs pour travailler sur la
dynamique épidémique avec la nra c'est
mieux sur certains projets de recherche
sont partage des données bien évidemment
est aussi partagée de données avec
l'europe puisque toutes nos données
surveillance nationale alimente les
travaux du centre européen de contrôle
et prévention des maladies ainsi qu'avec
l' oms
l'appui aux décideurs il est quotidien
nous transmettons ces bilans de manière
quotidienne le nombre de cas depuis le
19 mai à la direction générale de la
santé
les analyses de sur le suivi des
contacts sont en cours pour notamment
voir quelles sont leurs caractéristiques
et puis bien sûr
santé publique france dans sa dimension
établissements pharmaceutiques participe
à la gestion du stock des doses de
vaccins d'antiviraux et aux schémas
logistiques d'approvisionnement et donc
sur la prévention je laisserais mon
collègue françois beck vous détailler
les actions en cours à partir de la
diapositive suivante
madame la présidente mais d'amener et
messieurs les sénateurs donc je vais
vous parler des mesures de prévention
qui ont été prises donc à santé publique
france dans une logique de de continuum
oui d'accord donc les actions de
prévention
des actions de prévention que nous avons
mis en place sa santé publique france
ont été longs étaient dans un continuum
avec les données que le dr coignard
vient de vous présenter et puisqu'il ya
un point qui est très important c'est de
le ciblage des populations qu'on va
essayer d'atteindre avec ces différentes
mesures de prévention donc il est très
important pour nous de voir comment
l'épidémie évolue et comment en
particulier les profils des gens qui
sont atteints évolue donc
nous avons pu nous appuyer sur un
dispositif qui existait à santé publique
france 2 puis 2016 qui s'appelle sexo
safe qu'un dispositif à la fois digital
est présent sur le terrain dans les
milieux de la communauté lgbt et donc
dès le début 20 mai on a pu démarrer
grâce à ce dispositif un premier post
sur les réseaux sociaux et ensuite on a
mis en place une une faq le 27 mai il ya
eu un article
sur le site sexo sete.fr
complètement dédié à la variole du singe
pour expliquer ce qu'on savait à cette
époque là et puis au fur et à mesure on
a mis à disposition un certain nombre
d'outils pour les acteurs de terrain
pour les ars mais aussi pour les
associations en contact avec les les
différents lieux de consommation
sexuelle notamment
donc on a conçu des affiches une fiche
conseil dédié au personnel des
établissements les plus concernés par le
par la variole du singe et puis un flyer
pour
cours diffusion dans les lieux de
consommation sexuelle et surtout pour
les les marches des fiertés qui avait
lieu entre fin mai et début juillet dans
enfin dans tout dans beaucoup de grandes
villes françaises donc c'était très très
important en parallèle donc on a fait un
certain nombre de campagne sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis à partir de mi
juin on est passé à une communication
d'intensité plus forte avec une campagne
d'affichage plus soutenue dans les les
bars restaurants et clubs gay ou gay
friendly
une campagne digitale qui a été plus
intense aussi que s'appuyer sur les
réseaux sociaux et les sites
communautaires bon notamment committed
mr ben 10 et puis sur les applications
de rencontres aussi puisque l'enjeu se
situe et beaucoup là je pense par
exemple à ornette ou grinder est ensuite
il ya eu un partenariat avec d'autres
médias communautaires des radios
notamment radio fg et ji hwan radio
à partir de maintenant et depuis le donc
oui c'est ces temps de communication on
avait tous un coeur de messages qui
étaient autour du repérage des symptômes
qui ont pu évoluer d'ailleurs au cours
de nos cours de l'épidémie sur la
conduite à tenir et sur l'appel à un
professionnel de santé et donc le
troisième temps de communication
va être au tour à la fois du repérage
des symptômes mais aussi de la promotion
de la vaccination depuis l'avis rendu
par la chasse la has et puis l'ouverture
de d'une ligne de la distance monkey pox
info service
voilà donc on continue la campagne
digitale avec ses différentes
adaptations
et puis pour le terrain était conçu une
affiche pour les lieux de vaccination
une nouvelle fiche conseils pour les
personnels des lieux de convivialité et
puis un certain nombre de flyers qui est
donc évoque en plus le la vaccination
pour ce qui concerne les populations
autre que hsh donc aux hommes qui ont
des rapports sexuels avec d'autres
hommes on est aussi en train de
travailler à des fiches pour le le site
internet vaccination info service qui
lui a à la fois à destination des pros
de santé et et du grand public alors en
termes de performances on a donc une
campagne qui a réussi à atteindre de
nombreux
enfin de nombreuses personnes dans sa
cible puisque il ya eu plus de 200000
clics sur les bannières qui plus en plus
apparaître sur des sur des sites ciblés
et donc ça c'est un indicateur qui est
très intéressant parce que c'est un
geste que fait
le visiteur internet pour aller vers
l'information qu'on lui propose
et puis donc on s'est appuyé sur plus de
300 établissements ce qui a représenté à
peu près un million d'occasions de voir
les affiches qu'on diffusait et puis on
a un certain nombre d'autres indicateurs
sur lesquels je pourrais revenir juste
un tout dernier mot pour vous parler de
monkey pox info service donc c'est une
ligne qui est ouverte depuis aujourd'hui
vous voyez le numéro qui s'affiche ici
elle est ouverte de 8h à 23h tous les
jours de la semaine et donc c'est un
dispositif qui est extrêmement
intéressant pour compléter toutes les
autres actions prévention puisque ça
permet aux gens qui sont dans l'angoissé
dans l'inquiétude d'avoir un
interlocuteur
tout tout de suite et donc c'est voilà
c'est très complémentaire avec tout le
reste de ce qu'on a proposé
voilà et maintenant la dgs
merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs en complément de ce que mes
collègues on dit je vais essayer de vous
expliquer ce qu'on a fait depuis l'
alerte que vous
résumer bono coignard et dans quel
esprit on y travaille et quelles sont
les perspectives qu'on se donne en terme
de gestion peut-être deux messages pour
commencer d'abord sur la variole du
singe
rappeler que ça s'appelle la variole du
singe mais c'est pas la variole s'éteint
c'est un cousin de la variole et ça a
peu à voir avec le singe a été découvert
chez les singes le singe peut être hôte
de cette maladie mais le réservoir
animal et c'est important ce sont plutôt
les petits rongeurs et évidemment on a
des enjeux qu'on travaille avec l'ong
cesse et les autorités vétérinaires sur
ce sujet là le deuxième le deuxième
message à passer en introduction c'est
que comme l'ont très bien expliqué les
uns les autres il faut construire salle
en clair que ce n'est pas une maladie
des hommes ayant des relations sexuelles
avec des hommes mais que actuellement
l'épidémie que nous connaissons dans les
pays de l'hémisphère nord et en europe
est centré sur cette communauté
aujourd'hui et que ça peut diffuser
au-delà de ce cercle et qu' il n'y a pas
de did you syncra dit sur cette commune
était là avec cette maladie là et donc
il faut il faut le dire de manière très
claire
ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir ça a
été un petit peu rappelé ce sont des cas
importés depuis les zones d'endémie vers
nos pays il ya eu des cas ces dernières
années vers les etats unis vers le
royaume-uni beaucoup évidemment avec les
liens avec le nigeria israël en 2018
singapour en 2010 9 des événements
d'introduction avec des fréquences
répété qu'ils augmentent parce que les
l'augmentation du trafic aérien et
mondiale augmente et donc que la
probabilité ce type d'événement ou entre
ce qu'on n'avait pas vu ce sont des
circulations active au delà de quelques
cas secondaires éventuellement qui se
diffuse à large échelle et donc c'est ça
que on a vu avec la détection du premier
cas en france en le 19 mai
à partir de ce premier cas la première
chose qu'on a fait c'est qui est très
classique c'est qu'on a mis en place une
stratégie
autour du risque épidémique et
biologique on l'appelle dans le jargon
le reb et qui vise à avoir une stratégie
d'endiguement autour des premiers cas
d'une maladie qui ne circulent pas de
manière autochtones dans notre pays
alors c'est assez contraignant c'est à
dire qu'avec santé publique france alors
on l'a on a utilisé la définition de cas
qu'ils ont élaboré une conduite à tenir
qui vise à l'isolément des cas pendant
21 jours c'est long
à réaliser des investigations
à la fois en aval pour trouver les
éventuels cas secondaires
possiblement en amont aussi pour aller
chercher les lieux de contamination et
circonstances de contamination et
éventuellement les les documenter et
voir pouvoir avoir des actions quand on
trouve ce type ce type d'événement et ça
concerne plusieurs personnes mais c'est
évidemment pour coûteux en ressources
l'autre enjeu dans ce type d' alerte
c'est d'alerter les cliniciens avec un
certain nombre de messages on s'est
appuyé notamment évident par un aux
messages que vous connaissez depuis la
crise qu vite qu'ils sont les marchés
des gestes urgents mais aussi via une
mission qui s'appelle la mission correct
coordination du risque épidémique et
biologiques qui travaillent de manière
très opérationnelle avec les cliniciens
et c'est d'ailleurs un réseau de
cliniciens pour essayer de diffuser les
choses et tout simplement et le
professeur lescure vous le confirmera il
ya assez peu de spécialistes en france
qui ont eu à connaître des cas de monkey
pox avant cette émergence là et on vous
voir à quoi ça ressemble voir que les
lésions qui sont décrites et ça a été
parfaitement rappeler ne sont pas
exactement celles qu'on trouve en une de
google images et donc on peut passer à
côté du diagnostic pour plein de raisons
il ya toute cette phase d' alerte de
sensibilisation un travail qui a été
fait notamment au haut niveau de
l'iconographie pour montrer ce que
c'était ses lésions et commencer à les
repérer et sensibiliser également
dans les populations dont on commençait
à sentir que elles étaient les plus
ciblés passer ces informations-là
commencé à faire du record de 15 qui
permet ensuite de voir une augmentation
du nombre de cas et l'augmentation du
nombre de cas c'est évidemment une
circulation virale qui augmente mais
c'est aussi
un taux de détection qui augmente on
reperd plus de cas parce qu'il ya plus
de gens sensibilisés
on a mis assez rapidement en place une
vaccination des contacts à risque une
vaccination post exposition
premier cas le 19 mai on à la vie de la
chaise qui sort le 24 mai et sur cette
base là on prend un arrêté sur le
fondement de l'article l 31 1 31-1 qui
est blonde et parce que le vaccin
américain généraux sa une à mm aux etats
unis sur l'indication monkey pox mais
est néanmoins c'est un très bon vaccin
très utile dans cette indication là et
donc ça permet de l'utiliser donc ça a
été mise en oeuvre assez directement
l'avis de la has a été ensuite complété
le veut le 20 juin pour préciser les
indications chez les enfants et chez les
personnes qui avaient déjà été immunisés
contre la variole quand elle était plus
jeune et depuis le début de l'excitation
a priori on est à plus de 1000 injection
qui ont été réalisés on a également
saisi plusieurs fois le haut conseil de
la santé publique pour nous aider à
élaborer et diffuser des recommandations
recommandation sur la conduite à tenir
autour des cas et des sujets contacts
recommandations spécifiques pour les
personnes ayant un risque de formes
graves recommandations enfin plus
récemment sur les mesures de prévention
et les gestes barrière spécifique pour
cette manie évidemment tout ça se fait
avec des échanges continus avec les
associations et ce dès cette étape
la documentation des cas qui a été fait
par son public france et les agences
régionales de santé et les échanges avec
les cliniciens ont permis de comprendre
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est à
dire une circulation particulière dans
cette épidémie si dans la communauté des
personnes hsh multipartenaires
avec une localisation assez spécifique
des lésions ça a été rappelé par le
professeur x cure et les circonstances
de transmission qui a priori sont plutôt
très majoritairement des contacts très
rapproché à partir de là
ce qu'on peut dire c'est ce n'est pas
une infection sexuellement transmissible
au sens strict médical du terme mais qu'
il ya un certain nombre de facteurs qui
font que ça s'en rapproche
et donc tout l'enjeu en termes de
gestion à partir de ce moment là au
moment où ce tableau et merde c'est de
basculer de notre cadre risques
épidémiques et biologiques que je vous
expliquer à un cadre qui se rapproche
plus d'un gestion infectiologie qu plus
classique avec une forte composante de
santé sexuelle et reproductive et donc
c'est ça qu'on est en train de
travailler que je vous détailler
maintenant
sur la prise en charge des cas au départ
était centrée sur les établissements de
santé de référence et les établissements
habilités par les ars pour la gestion du
risque épidémique et biologiques on a
ouvert la prise en charge au départ à
l'ensemble des services de maladies
infectieuses et par suite on commence
pour la prise en charge en ville avec
les cegid
les cegid alors vous allez m'aider mais
c'est les centres gratuite d'information
de dépistage et je n'ai pas le dernier
des et je suis sûr que vous vous lavez
diagnostics
sont des centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit voilà pour le diagnostic des
siestes
vraiment des centres dédiés à la santé
sexuelle et vous voyez que c'est comme
ça qu'on fait la bascule du risque
épidémique va vers une prise en charge
plus large et plus et plus facilitantes
et c'est
de ce sont des centres de premiers
recours que les gens ont l'habitude de
consulter et donc c'est bien là où ils
vont donc c'est on a tout intérêt à ce
que le système se met en place vers la
vers la porte d'entrée naturelle pour
ces populations là et c'est bien ce
qu'on essaye de travailler on a passé
aussi labé le message que le premier
réflexe est tous le même c'est le
médecin traitant aussi et s'il ya un
doute le 15 c'est aussi fait pour
orienter et évidemment toutes les plates
formes qu'elles sont parfaitement les
informations ou orienter les pas
deux des échanges avec les cliniciens là
aussi le conserver sur pour vous en
parler est revenu au premier plan et
avec les associations aussi je dois dire
le fait que les lésions faisait
horriblement mal est donc évidemment on
est très sensible à cette cette
problématique est donc on a saisi les
sociétés savantes compétente pour
disposer d'un avis sur la prise en
charge spécifique de la douleur dans le
monkey pox on attend leur retour
incessament sous peu et ont évidemment
on va diffuser sa l'ensemble des
communautés clinique pour que ça puisse
faire et organiser des filières de prise
en charge spécifique de la douleur y
compris pour des patients qui ne
nécessiterait pas une hospitalisation au
sens strict mais
voilà
il faut qu'on traite ce sujet là et on
est en train de le traiter on fait
évoluer progressivement les définitions
de cas et la conduite à tenir parce que
maintenant qu'on a clairement un tableau
on n'a peut-être pas besoin de
documenter aussi complètement tous les
cas mais un échantillon de cas et on a
plus peut-être plus besoin de tester
tous les cas lorsque le diagnostic
clinique est absolument certain et
évident est que l'ensemble des
diagnostics différentiels et notamment
les ist ont été éliminés par ailleurs
puisque c'est bien l'ensemble de la
problématique qu'il faut traiter sur le
diagnostic pareil bascule du rêve vers
quelque chose de plus communautaire au
départ ce sont les laboratoires de
niveau p3 dans les os aire qui sont
habilités et vous savez que comme le
monkey pox est proche de la variole
ça fait l'objet de réglementations
particulières avec la nsa monde à
faciliter au maximum les choses mais il
ya des autorisations à obtenir pourquoi
laboratoire et le droit de détenir ce
type de prélèvement
on est en train d'ouvrir sa à l'ensemble
des laboratoire p3 de hospitalier et le
centre national de référence déploie la
technique diagnostic et assiste ces
laboratoires dans le déploiement des
techniques diagnostiques et on est en
train de travailler aussi l ouverture op
3 de ville et ça nécessite un certain
nombre d'âcres et le vent est donc on a
saisi la haute autorité de santé pour
l'inscrivait l'inscription à 90 lecture
des actes de biologie mais dit al et ona
temps là aussi leur avis rapidement pour
pouvoir déployer sa envie on a eu un
avis la société française de
microbiologie qui nous indiquent que sar
est préférable de rester en niveau p 3
compte tenu de la pathogénicité de cet
agent mais que dans certains territoires
ou d'ancêtres dans certaines situations
s'il ya une perte de chance pour le
patient on peut dégrader un petit peu ce
qu'on appelle paie de plus je rentre pas
dans le détail vous m'en excuserez mais
ce qui nous permet d'avoir un peu nous
notamment dans certains territoires pour
quand même avoir la technique diagnostic
et là aussi on y travaille
enfin c'est encore un peu tôt mais on
travaille d'ores et déjà avec l'asm pour
identifier les fabricants 2 trod de
tests rapides d'orientation diagnostique
de pouvoir en disposer de pouvoir
évaluer et notamment avec la mairesse et
mieux les performances de test était ce
parce qu'évidemment il n'est pas
question de déployer des thèses qui
n'auraient pas de bonnes performances et
qui induit en erreur sur le diagnostic
et donc on espère que à moyen terme
arrivera à développer on pense
évidemment que si on avait des trusts de
bonnes performances et que ça puisse
être positionnés dans les fameux s'est
vite dont on parlait tout à l'heure on a
quelque chose qui serait pas mal en
termes de diagnostic voilà on peut la
perspective et j'en viens à la
vaccination préventive et je sais que le
sujet vous intéresse
on a saisi oui je lis un peu la presse
et les réseaux sociaux aussi donc c'est
la saisine de la haute autorité de santé
oms la fête le 1er juillet la haute
autorité de santé nous a rendu son avis
le 8 juillet en nous indiquant trois
indications principales qui sont les
hommes ayant des relations sexuelles
avec les hommes multipartenaires et les
personnes trans multipartenaires les
gérants de lieu de convivialité avec
consommation sexuelle et puis les
personnes en situation de prostitution
et on en nous indiquant également
marginalement qu'elle ne reconnaît pas
d'indication prioriser pour la
vaccination des soignants mais que
au cas par cas pour des soignants
particulièrement exposés parce qu'ils
voient des patients monkey pox tous les
jours ou qu'ils ont à manipuler des
échantillons de tous les jours ça peut
se faire au cas par cas le dernier point
et c'est important dans la discussion
c'est que la haute autorité ne nous dit
aussi bien sûr que cette indication là
elle ne se fait pas au détriment
de l'indication précédente qui est la
vaccination post exposition sont deux
choses différentes les deux indications
que coexistent et la vaccination post
exposition est prioritaire sur la
vaccination préventive
puisque en effet à face à un risque
immédiat versus un risque autant c'est
donc suite à la réception de la ville le
8 juillet
il a été annoncé le jour même que la vie
elle est suivie on a envoyé des messages
à l'ensemble des ars pour
leur indiquer la vie et qui fait qu'on
travaille à l'élargissement des centres
de vaccination ils se sont mis en ordre
de marche tout de suite on vous avait
déjà un petit peu anticipé
et on a travaillé bien sûr avec santé
publique france dans sa composante est
bien établissements pharmaceutiques avec
l'asm pour essayer de d'organiser le
schéma logistique et puis lever
l'ensemble des francs technique qui peut
y avoir notamment les les les conditions
de conservation et de transport de ce
type de vaccin sont pas là sont pas
complètement simple et donc fait très
attention parce qu'il s'agit pas non
plus de faire n'importe quoi avec ces
vaccins
on appelait on a fait sortir un nouvel
arrêté l 31 31-1 le dimanche 10 pour
permettre de lever l'ensemble des freins
réglementaires qui nous gênait pour
déployer cette vaccination
donc là aussi extrêmement de manière
extrêmement volontariste à dire que on a
arrêté ce n' est qu' il n'y a pas besoin
de faire depuis une pharmacie
hospitalière ce qu'on appelle une
rétrocession nominatives si on veut
vacciner par exemple dans les cegid on a
fait lever
le fait que les centres de vaccination
ne pouvait pas vaccinés pour ce type de
v de vaccin puisque elle ne pouvait
vacciner que pour les indications du
calendrier vaccinal et il n'a pas d'un
calendrier vaccinal
et puis on a rappelé que
c'est un vaccin la prescription médicale
mais que bien sûr les infirmiers et les
infirmières pouvait réaliser l'injection
sur sur prescription médicale
les ars ont travaillé là aussi à
l'ouverture des centres à l'heure où je
vous parle on a plus de 70 centres de
vaccination qui sont référencés
elles ont référencé sur les sites des
agences régionales de santé et on les a
agrégé au niveau du site sante.fr où il
ya un onglet maintenant dédié monkey pox
donc sante.fr slash et monkey pox j'ai
regardé ce matin il y avait 72 centres
évidemment les prises de rendez-vous
commence c'est ce qu'on avait dit ça
commencerait à partir de cette semaine
et en plus on a une semaine avec le 14
juillet au milieu s'est pas complètement
saint pée idéal mais on fait avec et et
il ya des premières des premiers créneau
qui se sont ouverts d'autres qui vont
suivre et puis on va on va arriver à une
vitesse de croisière j'espère assez
rapidement maintenant je voudrais quand
même souligner le fait qu'on est parmi
les premiers pays à faire cette
vaccination préventive le royaume-uni le
canada et l'allemagne ont commencé mais
on est on est dans les mêmes temps et on
est très peu de pays à le faire à ce
stade
l'enjeu ça a été des vendredis de
redimensionner les stocks qui étaient
prépositionnés dans les régions
puisqu'on avait pré-positionné des doses
pour la vaccination des sujets contacts
et qu'il faut augmenter ça donc c'est
des circuits logistiques importants et
on y travaille et
on continue à consolider et à amplifier
les circuits d'approvisionnement sur la
communication peut-être un mot parce que
c'est une question que je me posais sur
sur les stocks qui sont couverts par le
secret défense donc j'ai vécu cette
question là j'en suis d donner c'est
quoi le secret défense c'est la
composition et le capacitaire du stock
et donc j'en prendrais pas évidemment
pour les rayons vous vous comprenez dans
le détail sur la communication
les collègues de santé publique france
en ont beaucoup parlé mais je voudrais
quand même insisté sur le fait qu on a
un dialogue très rapprochés avec les
associations et un dialogue que je
trouve de qualité je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle en prenant soin de qualité et
hebdomadaire on a une vision confiance
hebdomadaire depuis le début de cette
alerte avec elle pour expliquer ce qu'on
fait et prendre les remonter terran et
ce qui va ce qui va pas et on se dit
assez franchement les choses le numéro
un le numéro vert qui est ouvert depuis
aujourd'hui et dont je rappelle le
numéro 08 cents à 90 81 69 et puis tous
les travaux qui ont été rappelés par
françois beck sur donc voila vous voyez
on a fait beaucoup de choses dans un
temps restreint parce qu'il faut
toujours se méfier du bief historique
finalement ça fait qu'un mois et demi
que cette alerte a commencé c'est un
temps relativement courte
je tiens ici l'on voit rendre hommage
aux équipes qui travaillent avec moi sur
ce sujet là ils sont totalement
mobilisées tard le soir le week-end
compris on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour
déployer au maximum
les choses le plus vite possible
j'espère qu'on va arriver à lever tous
les freins qui reste en tout cas vous
pouvez être assurés qu'on est totalement
déterminée pour lutter face à cette
nouvelle épidémie et j'espère que tout
ce que nous avons appris dans le cadre
de l'accord vide va nous servir pour
jets à ça au lieu
merci beaucoup donc nous allons passer
de cette présentation nous allons passer
aux différentes questions et j'ai
d'abord corinne imbert
merci la présidente merci messieurs pour
pour vous vous exposez
j'aurais évidemment plusieurs questions
si j'ai un temps imparti madame la
présidente à la fois
non papa pas tout mais non mais j'ai
quand même une sélection de plusieurs
questions même si certains sujets
évidemment ont été abordés
par les différentes prises de parole
tout d'abord concernant la maladie et sa
diffusion en france on voit un nombre de
cas recensés à la fois j'allais dire
relativement modeste puisque on partait
de 500 ko au 5 juillet mais avec quelque
part un emballement puisqu'on est à plus
de 915 quelques jours ainsi jours plus
tard
quelles craintes avez-vous en termes de
d'emballement de cette épidémie et en
terme de mortalité j'ai bien entendu à
ce jour il n'y a pas de de décès liés à
cette pathologie
en france on a vu qu'il y avait un taux
de mortalité important même s'ils
étaient plus faibles en afrique de
l'ouest
malgré tout ça fait ça fait un taux de
en afrique de l'ouest de 10% est ce que
vous craignez que ce taux de 10% puisse
atteindre les patients dans notre dans
notre pays
donc c'est non que vous nous avez ce
chiffre de 900 mouska est ce qu il fait
état de la réalité de l'épidémie et
égouts estimez vous que certains cas
sont asymptomatiques et nous ont mal
dépistée et même si j'ai entendu que le
délai de diagnostic était réduit
et si
le déploiement de tron était en cours
pour avoir donc des tests rapides
d'orientation diagnostique est ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter les mesures
prises pour favoriser le dépistage au
delà de ces trod
concernant les traitements préventifs ou
curatifs
effectivement la question des vaccins
nous intéresse fortement
comment expliquer le décalage même si
vous l'avez dit monsieur de la direction
générale de la monsieur lazhar mondiale
de la santé vous avez souligné que la
france faisait partie des premiers pays
à ouvrir la vaccination pré-exposition
après le canada le royaume uni
l'allemagne mais on a un petit décalage
bien sûr vous avez certainement on a
attendu l'avis de la haute autorité de
santé mais comment vous expliquer ce
décalage est alors même si j'ai aussi
bien entendu nous l'avons tous entendue
que le la notion de stocks étaient
couverts par le secret défense ou mais
quand même permettait de nous interroger
sur le stuff dit suffisant alors vous
allez peut-être pas me répondre parce
que vous me direz secret défense mais
j'ai quand même entendu que vous nous
expliquer que la vaccination post
exposition devait rester prioritaire par
rapport à la vaccination pré-exposition
il me semble que c'est ce que vous avez
dit voilà donc ça veut dire si elle
reste prioritaire c'est qu'à un moment
donné on va gérer des stocks sauf erreur
de ma part sinon on se poserait pas la
question ou alors celle là
l'épidémie va s'enflammer et d'où les
mesures mises mise en place
la haute autorité de santé recommande
deux injections ce jour à 28 jours des
cas
ce délai entre deux injections pouvant
aller jusqu'à quelques semaines je crois
que c'est exactement ça je cite la haute
autorité de santé ça veut dire quoi
quelques semaines et là encore est ce
que c'est pas une façon de gérer des
stocks
l' agence européenne era aurait passé
des commandes de vaccins
alors peut-être que j'aurai encore
secret défense mais la france at elle
souscrit à ces commandes groupe au
niveau européen et le gouvernement
français choisit les réalistes ils
décommandent parallèle
et concernant les vaccins utilisés
pouvez vous nous donner des informations
quant à leur efficacité
et comment cela a souvent été l'objet de
craintes dans le cas de la pandémie de
kobe quant à leur innocuité qu'est ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de ces vaccins
voilà des barrages la vaccination d'île
de france semble difficile est ce un
problème de logistique ou est-ce qu'on
en revient un problème de manque de
doses accessible et à quelle date des
vaccinations seront elles possibles en
région voilà je vais m'arrêter là
voilà oui bon je m'arrête là jour merci
très bien les bonnes questions on va
prendre deux autres intervenants et
ensuite on répondra et on prend enfin
une autre salve de questions florence
lassarade berlin jaune oui merci pour
compléter un petit peu les questions
médicales moi qui suis pédiatre et qui
sait quand maternité en redoutent en
redoutent le virus de l'herpès génital
et et des dégâts qui peut produire chez
le nouveau né ce qui a déjà un protocole
qui a été donné pour la femme enceinte
qui pourraient être porteuses de de
lésions génitales
suspecte est ce qu'on fait une
césarienne un peu
systématiquement est ce que ces sujets
ont été évoqués
deuxièmement
moi aussi j'avais des questions sur le
délai des faces d'efficacité de la
vaccination
est ce que on peut envisager la
vaccination la femme enceinte je ne le
pense pas mais vous lui direz et enfin
tu en connais dans la rubrique
vaccination puisse moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus avec l'opex tu à
propos de
deux vaccins avisé oro génitales est ce
que le vaccin du papillomavirus
se diffuse ou s.koné on est encore
justement est-ce que le vaccin du papier
ou un virus a pas été victimes de
l'épidémie de covin et sa publicité
également puisqu'on avait un vaccin à
viser vraiment génitales et bernard
jomier est ce qu'on pourra voir les
slides qui ont été présentes merci
censure des métalleux et le professeur
lescure nous enverra
merci
bon mes questions sont assez on va dire
similaires ou à celle de corinne amer
mais
je de façon moins diplomate quel comme
d'habitude ce que je trouve que le
discours que notamment la direction
générale de la santé nous a offert est
quand même un très beau discours bien
lissés mais ne correspond pas exactement
à la réalité
de fait du déroulement des faits vous
avez
rappelé avec justesse que le premier
avis de la haute autorité de santé la
première recommandation ces femmes et
autour de la question de la variole du
singe le 20 23 24 mai à ce moment là et
il est marquant de constater que depuis
alors il ya eut saisi et recommandations
vous ne l'avez décrit mesfar mais c'est
le moment où l'allemagne elle elle
commandait 240000 vaccin pour sa
population c'était femmes et voilà et
vous à la question des commandes de
vaccins nous n'avons toujours pas de
réponse alors où on a besoin on espère
qu'on va l'avoir ce matin parce qu'on
est le 12 ou 13 juillet mais pour le
moment il n'y a eu aucune réponse à
cette question voilà le décalage
concret et si on reprend mais je vais
être court parce qu'un après nantes l'a
demandé d'être court les chronologies
sur les états unis ou sur le canada sur
les autres grands pays sont concernés
est à peu près du même ordre on est par
rapport à ces pays largement en retard
comme d'habitude
deuxième point
la situation actuelle pour nous pour
l'évaluer nous avons besoin premièrement
d'avoir des prévisions des
épidémiologistes et ce qui est marquant
c'est que on en a pas alors est ce que
c'est le nombre de facteurs
d'incertitude qui rend les prévisions
trop complexes avec des écarts qui
serait telle qu'on ne pourrait pas en
tirer une leçon en termes après deux
mesures à prendre mais en tout état de
cause
on a on a dans les saisies d'avis qu'ils
nous ont été exposés on n'a pas entendu
de saisine avis sur les prévisions
épidémiologie et sur les notamment sur
les données précisent que les demandes
et corinne imbert
je vais donc vous poser juste quatre
questions 1 celle des prévisions
épidémiologique 2 la question du nombre
de vaccins qui sont disponibles pour la
population générale et personne ici ne
vous demande quelles sont les stocks de
vaccins qui relèvent de la sécurité
nationale
nous on ne peut pas opposer le secret
défense à la population générale pour
savoir quels sont les vaccins qui sont
disponibles pour la population générale
ça ce n'est pas du relève que ça ne
ressort pas de la sécurité nationale et
de la défense et cet argument la dgs il
est pour moi irrecevable troisièmement
donc les commandes de vaccins quand
avez-vous commandé des vaccins et
quelques ailes nombre de vaccins avez
vous commandez et quatrièmement le
dispositif d'information en direction
des populations donc un travail effectué
avec un certain nombre d'associations
notamment communautaires mais on
aimerait avoir plus d'information sur
le dispositif d'information
sur
de la population sur la variole du singe
sans merci
à répondre à ces questions pendant
professeur lescure je vous propose de
démarrer sur des questions qui vous
concerne et puis on prendra à suivre
tu aller vite non mais
pour moi j'assure pas un mba les
réponses
vous annoncer des chiffres qui est je
pense qu'il faut être très modeste avec
cette cette maladie qui est extrêmement
mal connu et probablement décrite dans
des conditions d'accès au diagnostic et
aux soins qui sont incomparables avec ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui et qui permet de
probablement qu'ils induisent
probablement une approximation
importante
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas que la
mortalité
sur dans nos pays soient celles de 10%
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on observe
avec des milliers de patients qui ont
été identifiées il n'y a pas de décès
sous contrôle de spf aujourd'hui ni en
france ni dans d'autres pays de la zone
nord est dont + compte plus qu on a plus
de sept ou huit mille cas documentés ça
vous donne une petite idée de la
différence qu'il ya entre la mortalité
annoncé en 9 en afrique de l'ouest pour
les 10% est ce qu'on observe ici je ne
crois pas que ce soit lié uniquement au
terrain des patients qui sont touchés
chez nous qui n'ont pas de facteur de
risque de formes graves que je vous ai
décrit c'est qu'ils sont les enfants les
femmes enceintes et les personnes
immunodéprimées je pense qu'il ya une
question dénominateur et de difficultés
a estimé dans les pays du sud la
létalité précise de la maladie
la deuxième question par rapport à la
crainte vis-à-vis de la diffusion je
pense que spf ou la dgs pourra avoir des
éléments de réponse ce qui est sûr c'est
que
si on a la réponse que je viens de vous
donner sur la gravité ou la mortalité
pourrait éventuellement différé si
l'épidémie venait se diffuser chez des
personnes à risque de formes graves
enfants femmes enceintes mais déprimé
donc ça prend c'est vrai que en termes
de de stratégie on veut éviter la
diffusion au delà de cette communauté en
partie est en grande partie à cause de
ces raisons là
la question et
et parra et la question pardon par
rapport au dépistage et au délai du
diagnostic je pense que 1 et peut-être
spf aussi y aura des éléments de réponse
les circuits sont mis en place
progressivement l'offre au début comme
vous l'expliqué le dr clément lazarus
était centrée sur les établissements de
santé de référence et donc il ya eu un
engorgement assez rapide par rapport aux
nombres de nombre de cas qui étaient
essentiellement centrés sur l'île de
france le déploiement d'autres centres
pouvant effectuer le diagnostic a permis
de réduire le délai de diagnostic et
l'autre raison aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
un diagnostic qui est permis sur une
approche clinique dans des équipes
expérimentées on n'a plus besoin de
faire une documentation virologique
pour les traitements effectivement on a
des traitements c'est pour ça que l'âme
point de vue sanitaire on n'est pas très
inquiet d'une part parce que je vous ai
dit que la transmission interhumaine
était très faible dans les zones
d'endémie est donc au-delà des modes de
transmission spécifique décrit dans
cette communauté je ne pense pas que la
diffusion en population générale soit à
craindre dans les proportions
inquiétantes et puis on a des outils
thérapeutiques curatif
on a lutté comme guy matte qui est un
traitement oral anti viral on a le
principe d'offrir qui est aussi un
traitement antiviral en termes de
disponibilité pour le moment les
contraintes sont en train de se réduire
mais on pourra très prochainement avoir
accès à ces médicaments
dont l'efficacité
semble
intéressante assez puissante en termes
d'effets antiviral mais qui sont issus
de données animales avec une tolérance
qui allaient qui semble correct
et pour
vos questions spécifiques sur les
populations particulières femmes
enceintes et enfants le tekori mater
indiqué à partir de 13 kg de poids
corporel environ deux ans lebrun sido
faut virer indiqué dès la naissance et
chez la femme enceinte on peut utiliser
les immunoglobulines anti vaccine qu'ils
ont
mais avec probablement ici aussi un
accès difficile mais toutes ces
questions ont été anticipées
je pense que sur l'efficacité vaccinale
on a peu de données sur
le vaccin
vis-à-vis de monkey pox puisque c'est le
vaccin antivariolique classique elle est
estimée autour de 85% dans les limites
et de la robustesse des informations et
des données qu'on on peut avoir on sait
sur la vaccination antivariolique que la
mémoire de la vaccination et donc
l'efficacité de la vaccination
si on prend modèle variole est assez est
stable et perdure longtemps dans au
cours du temps
et puis je pense qu'en ce qui me
concerne
je peux m'arrêter là il y avait les
données de tolérance sur la vaccination
là aussi on assure la troisième
génération un c'est pas le vaccin qui a
été donné dans les années jusque dans
les années 80 qui était un vaccin de
première génération qui était
relativement avec dès qu'ils étaient
pourvus d'effets indésirables non
négligeable sur ce 3 sur ce vaccin de
troisième génération qui est aussi
réalisée à partir d'un vaccin vivant
mais non répliquent hâtif et donc on a
aussi un recul avec d'autres c'est une
stratégie vaccinale utilisée pour
d'autres agents infectieux et on a un
recul en termes de tolérance qui est
tout à fait favorable
qui continue santé peu et de france et
ensuite monsieur la série mais dont je
me remette de répondre peut-être de
manière groupée puisque certaines
questions sont similaires donc j'ai bien
noté une question sur un éventuel
emballement c'est en fait très lié aux
questions que vous avez posé également
sur des modèles de prévision donc je
répondrai à ces déviations ensemble
également sur les formes et
éventuellement asymptomatique et enfin
sur les questions de comparaison par
rapport à d'autres pays européens
notamment l'angleterre donc vous êtes
sur les formes asymptomatiques d'abord
toutes ces questions je le précise
feront l'objet de discussions plusieurs
fois par semaine avec nos collègues des
autres agences européennes on a deux à
trois réunions hebdomadaires où
effectivement les pays font part de leur
expérience et donc sur la question des
cas symptomatiques aujourd'hui la
question n'est pas résolue très peu
d'évidence
aucune publication revue par les pairs
nos collègues belges ont fait état
d' éventuellement trois cas alors
asymptomatiques ou possi symptomatique
c'est toute la difficulté on peut avoir
des formes cliniques très frustre
éventuellement non reconnue notamment si
les éruptions sont sont peu disséminés
voir muqueuses et donc la question n'est
pas résolue et on ne sait pas de toute
façon même pour ceux ce qu'ils reportent
en belgique si les personnes étaient
contagieuses donc la recherche poursuit
et je pense que voilà ça fait
effectivement l'objet d'une attention
soutenue en lien avec nos collègues
cliniciens pour pouvoir les documenter
mais à ce jour il n'y a pas d'évidence
solide sur le sujet sur la question
de craintes d'un éventuel emballement en
fait nous dès le début de cette épidémie
on s'est mis en contact avec des équipes
de modélisation avec qui on travaille
depuis en fait de longues années et
notamment depuis la qu'ovide et donc on
partage nos données de surveillance avec
trois équipes de modélisation et en
navarre est une réunion de travail ce
matin à laquelle je ne suis pas allé
mais des collègues de mon équipe y sont
pour faire les tables leurs premiers
résultats donc je ne peux pas vous en
parler je ne les connais pas ce que l'on
connaît par contre ce sont les travaux
de nos collègues anglais ils ne seront
publiés le 8 juillet un technical
briefing où effectivement leurs
conclusions sont très prudente puisque
en gros ils ont d'énormes incertitudes
désintéresse de confiance dans leurs
prévisions qui font qu'on ne sait pas si
on va être sur un plateau ou sur une
augmentation donc il ne conclut pas le
cdc conduit également des travaux de
modélisation mais là plus pour évaluer
les stratégies de prévention et
notamment vaccinale mais n'a pas
prévue de projection donc voilà donc on
devrait nous avoir des projections
nationales dans un proche avenir en tout
cas je l'espère mais j'attendrai de
prendre connaissance de lait des travaux
des équipes de recherche avec qui nous
collaborons sur ce sujet
concernant enfin la question d'un
éventuel retard sur les anglais par
ailleurs leur épidémie a démarré avant
la nôtre et on est assez sûre du sujet
je n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure mais
notre premier cas date du 19 mai on a
vérifié par acquis de conscience parce
qu'on peut toujours éventuellement raté
les signaux on a regardé nos données de
surveillance syndromique je pense que
vous connaissez on a un système de
surveillance syndromique qui nous permet
de recueillir des données syndromique de
tous les services d'urgence et des
services hospitaliers en en temps réel
et on a donc interrogé ces données de
surveillance syndromique de manière
rétrospective sur les mois précédents et
nous n'avons pas identifié de signal
permettant de suspecter des cas de
manque et pax en france avant ce premier
cas du 19 mai on a par contre à
l'occasion effectivement de cette
interrogation de nos données de
surveillance syndromique identifié une
épidémie de varicelle mais bon voilà
c'est valable en tout cas on a fait
cette vérification est donc l'épidémie
en france est quand même assez décalé et
d'une intensité très inférieure à celle
observée en angleterre en allemagne ou
en espagne sur la question d'un éventuel
sous diagnostic là encore le plus
important c'est de sensibiliser les
patients et on a insisté tout à l'heure
effectivement sur le fait d'informer les
cliniciens
actuellement lazarus à souligner
effectivement qu'il fallait pouvoir
faire connaître des cliniciens qui ne
connaissent pas cette maladie à quoi
elle ressemblait donc il ya un gros
travail fait par les cliniciens de
photothèque notamment pour diffuser ces
informations
et puis il faut sensibiliser les
patients aussi pour qu'ils consultent si
un patient ne consultent pas on ne peut
pas effectivement avoir connaissance de
ce cas voilà pour quelques éléments de
réponse
alors je vais essayer de répondre aux
questions des vaccins mais comme il ya
une question sur les
rapides entre les tests et après je
reviens à la question des vaccins ce
qu'on a fait pour essayer de faciliter
le le diagnostic et le dépistage vous
avez parfaitement raison simple c'est
important c'est d'une part d'essayer
d'élargir au maximum 1 les électeurs et
de les laboratoires qui peuvent
technique et c'est vraiment les
prélèvements ils peuvent se faire
partout y compris en ville et pour le
prélèvement il ya un acte qui est prévue
à la nomenclature des actes de biologie
médicale et donc ya pas de problème tous
les laboratoires de biologie médicale en
ville peuvent faire le prélèvement et
éventuellement l'oeil alors cédé
s'appuie sont pas toujours simple mais
on y travaille en lien avec avec les
biologistes donc je serais parti
prélèvement est un an sur la partie
technique âge je vous ai dit il ya une
réglementation qui est lié au fait que
le monkey pox et un orthodoxe virus que
c'est potentiellement un agent de la
menace et la réglementation motte donc
donc il ya des autorisations à avoir
compris vos pouvoirs technique et
ensuite conserver éventuellement ces
échantillons avec la haine et c'est mon
travail sur les sur l'allégement de
cette réglementation aujourd'hui qu'on a
un virus qui circule sur le territoire
je peux pas préjuger de de ski de ce qui
arrive à mais c'est quelque chose qui
est bien pris en compte suite au niveau
de la biosécurité il s'agit à la fois
d'élargir les effecteurs et je vous ai
dit qu'on est passé d seul laboratoire
p3 des établissements de santé de
référence à l'ensemble des laboratoire
p3 hospitalier et bientôt si il ya la
vie à un avis de l' achat sur la n1b m
olio p3 deux villes ça permet de
desserrer et même que là où il n'y a pas
de laboratoires de niveau p 3 on
pourrait être dégradée encore un peu et
les choses pour qu'il y ait un accès au
diagnostic dans les territoires qui est
qui en auraient besoin on fait aussi
attention au fait que quand on dégrade
les les niveaux de biosécurité
évidemment il s'agit pas de mettre à
risque les travailleurs dans l'est dans
les laboratoires donc il ya un enjeu qui
est important là et il faut pas faire
non plus n'importe quoi et puis la
deuxième
champ d'action c'est sur les fraudes
celui d'être tout à l'heure c'est pas
encore pour tout de suite parce que il
n'y a plus y en a pas qui sont encore
avec ses textures sur le sur le marché
on y travaille avec la nsm selon 2
trouver quelques actions les
fournisseurs qui ont des têtes et qui
ont des capacités d'approvisionnement
et puis deuxièmement dès qu'on pourra en
avoir un petit peu travaillé notamment
avec les équipes de recherche et
notamment avec les us air qui voit
beaucoup de patients à évaluer dans le
cadre d'un protocole de recherche les
performances de ses preuves pour voir
s'ils ont une qualité satisfaisante
puisqu'il s'agit pas d'avoir plein de
faux négatifs ou plein de faux positifs
avec des dispositifs qui ne marchera pas
si on a un conditions réunies d'avoir
une capacité à avoir des
approvisionnements et des tests de
bonnes performances et effectivement on
aura tout intérêt et je crois que tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus à
pouvoir déployer c'est rod et notamment
en ville dans l'est cegid j'espère avoir
répondu à vos questions sur cette partie
là j'en reviens sur
la partie l'accent sur la question du
décalage avec les autres pays
bruno coignard a répondu à la fois sur
le décalage dans le temps et les
surintensités je voudrais simplement
préciser une chose sur les avis de la
chaise pour pour qu'on parle tous bien
de la même chose c'est que l'avis du vin
mais qui a été rendue publique le 24 mai
il ne traite que de la vaccination
post-exposition que la vaccination des
sujets contacts il ne ne traite pas de
la vaccination préventive ça c'est la
vie qui a été rendue la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas la même chose c'est pas
le même dimensionnement s'est pas
laissée pas les mêmes circuler donc
c'est bien en redimensionnant suite à
ces cet avis est qui et qui a lieu
actuellement sur les stocks
sur le secret défense
pour être précis ce qui est couvert par
secret défense je les dis c'est le
capacitaires et la composition du stock
c'est dans le cadre du plan variole et
c'est un plan qui est piloté par le
secrétaire régional défense et de la
sécurité nationale et donc il m'a ne
m'appartient absolument pas de rentrer
dans ce détail là ce que je peux vous
dire et j'espère que ça répondra à une
partie de vos questions d'abord qu'on a
un stock suffisant de vaccins
à la fois contre la variole et pour
engager la vaccination
monkey pox préventive près préventive et
paye pas ses expositions vous avez
raison madame la présidente et ça me
permet de répondre à une autre de vos
questions sur la priorisation des
indications la priorisation qui est fait
par la chaise ce n'est pas une
priorisation de gestion des stocks ça
pourrait l'être s'ils avaient besoin
mais en l'occurrence c'est vraiment une
priorisation de médical de souvenirs oui
oui mais gégé les mêmes souvenirs je les
partage avec vous mais c'est bien une
indication médicale entre la gestion
d'un risque immédiat est avérée pour des
personnes qui ont eu un contact à risque
documenté et évaluer et qui sont
susceptibles de développer la maladie
dans internet très courts et une
vaccination préventive pour une
population avec un risque potentiel qui
est un sur risque par rapport à
l'ensemble de la population générale
donc on n'est pas dans le même niveau de
risques et donc c'est logique d'avoir
cette priorisation dans les indications
silva
sur les stocks on a des niveaux de ceux
qui sont suffisants pour traiter ces
indications là et il ya des commandes
qui sont et qui sont payés
complémentaires qui ont été passé dès le
début de cette alerte et il ya une
première livraison qui est déjà
intervenu et on a des prochaines
livraisons qui sont programmés en août
en septembre et à fin de l'année et on
est en cours d'instruction d'autres
commandes supplémentaires et je ne
manque pas dans le détail sur ce qui est
livré
on a des stocks et des stocks
stratégiques plusieurs milliers de doses
qui sont déjà sur le terrain
notamment en ile de france puisque
l'évidence est là où le jeu se concentre
le gros de l'épidémie et plus plusieurs
milliers qui vont être stockés à brève
échéance on est en train de faire les
payes pour les réapprovisionnements et
les réassorts dans les différents
centres de vaccination en fonction de
leur ouverture avec les ars et il ya
déjà des programmations qui sont en
cours pour les semaines à venir donc les
doses sont en train d'arriver sur le
terrain il y avait déjà les deux qui
avaient été prépositionnés pour la
vaccination
post-exposition là on parle des
réapprovisionnements pré-exposition il
ya déjà des doses il y en aura qui sont
déjà prévus donc tout ça et est en train
de tu es en charge
de manière assez forte sur les sur les
commandes j'ai répondu sur la femme
pharmacovigilance effectivement c'est du
domaine de l'année c'est mon suisse a
évidemment de manière rapprochée et avec
santé publique france puisque ce sont
des vaccins qui sont des stockés depuis
le stock stratégique de santé publique
france
et je crois que j'ai répondu à toutes
vos questions quand vous dites suffisant
vous avez évalué la cible
ça fait combien de personnes
sur les délais vous avez pardon
sur les des effectivement ça nous donne
une souplesse logistique mais c'est
comme pour les autres vaccins alors qu'
il ya une indication d'écart entre les
deux et puis on peut on peut y aller la
semaine suivante où la semaine des as
trahi ça ne pose pas de problème médical
si vous voulez donc c'est ça autre
réflexion pour nous il souplesse
logistique au 6 mai mais c'est comme
pour les autres actions j'ai envie de
vous dire mon professeur lescure vous
pouvez préciser la cible
si je peux présicé sosie mais j'avais
des sources mais on a on avait on avait
les chercheurs en sciences sociales
avait ont des données assez précis sur
les prêteurs en france sur les personnes
les hommes ayant des rapports sexuels
avec des hommes pratiquant le les
partenaires multiples et donc si vous
faites l'association des prêteurs des
vih positifs ou négatifs ayant ce type
de conduite à risque vous arrivez sur un
total d'environ 120 mille personnes
avant qu'on passe aux autres questions
est ce que le fait de cibler uniquement
les personnes que vous venez définir
est-ce qu'on va passer à côté de cas
chez d'autres personnes c'est ma
question est est ce que est ce que en
plus à un côté très stigmatisante donc
comment vous vous traiter ça en terme de
communication
alors de la prison sur la question
va-t-on passer à côté d'autres profils
c'est l'objet effectivement est notre
priorité actuellement dans les démarches
de surveillance on a bien caractérisés
aujourd'hui la principale populations à
risque hommes ayant des rapports sexuels
avec les hommes notamment
multipartenaires mais nous restons
vigilants pour justement détecter
d'éventuelles modifications avec des cas
qui seraient rapportés de manière plus
fréquente chez des femmes chez des
enfants bien évidemment ou chez les
travailleurs du sexe par exemple
aujourd'hui les données dont j'ai fait
ça voilà ce sont les dernières données
de nous disposons mais nous concentrons
bien évidemment nos investigations sur
ces formes qui serait atypique
oui merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs pour ces
ces éléments en fait non mais question
vents vont poursuivre ce qui vous a déjà
été posée parce que effectivement le
discours on va dire officiel un de la
dgs paraît voilà on maîtrise tout on
tient tout on a tout anticiper donc a
pris en compte visiblement la pandémie
du corps d'un virus mais ça c'est sur le
papier mais en même temps on n'a aucun
chiffre
on est obligé de vous croire sur parole
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué vous
l'avouerez pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes alors moi je veux d'abord
une première chose je ne comprends pas
votre argument de secret défense je ne
vois pas ce que le la secret la défense
vient faire dans l'histoire il me semble
pas mais peut-être que je me suis ça m'a
échappé il me semble il ne semble pas
que le secret défense était invoquée
pour pour la pandémie pour un virus mais
je voilà donc pourquoi tout d'un coup
ils seraient invoquée ici c'est ma
première première question deuxième
question
docteur lazarus est pas très bien
compris parce que vous avez dit en
parlant donc de cette variole du singe
que ce n'était pas une infection
sexuellement transmissible
mais ça sent la prochaine et là on y est
soit sexuellement transmissibles et s'en
approcher là non plus je je vois pas
donc est-ce que je peux avoir quelques
petites précisions là dessus ensuite
vous avez dit que les centres de
vaccination vous aviez donné des des
consignes pour qu'ils soient ouverts
quand les plus qu'ils soient ouverts 70
centres de vaccination si j'aime bien
écouter
mais est-ce que c'est 70 centres de
vaccination vont avoir les nombre de
doses à la fois en préventif et en
curatif qu'est-ce que voilà est ce que
on peut avoir plus de précision là
dessus et puis
je voudrais savoir aussi au niveau de
l'anticipation c'est à dire par rapport
aux commandes et par rapport à la
production parce qu'on a bien vu là
pendant le grand à virus que on moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que on était
plus que faible pour pas dire inexistant
en termes de production des vaccins là
je voudrais savoir si la france est en
capacité de produire ces vaccins et puis
peut-être savoir également ses vaccins
ils viennent de quel lago séquelles
labos qui qui qui fournit qui fournit
les vaccins on est dépendant de quoi
pour savoir à quelle sauce on peut être
mangé ces files heures ou d'autres voilà
merci davance alors vérone et guillotin
et pour terminer l'année prochaine alors
merci madame la présidente je décide
d'aller vite dans mes questions j'en
avais plein mais elles ont quasiment
toutes étaient à l'ordre du jour donc je
vais les oublier la prévention
épidémiologue trop d l'évaluation des
vaccins ses trois premières je voulais
poser je les ai vécus il en reste deux
est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui par
définition sur une endémie une épidémie
ou est-ce qu'on surveille uniquement des
cas sporadiques fin jeu voilà à peu près
qu'elle ça quel stade on est sa première
question et la deuxième c'est sûr je
n'ai pas très bien compris sur la
transmission 1 est-ce qu'on est sur une
mallette visiblement qui était
tranquille et transmise au départ par le
rongeur à l'homme donc est-ce qu'il faut
que ce soit mordu fin je sais pas et ça
impliquerait des préventions sur les
métiers exposés aux rongeurs et la
deuxième transmission interhumaine est
ce que c'est une transmission de contact
pur ou est ce que c'est une transmission
avec une composante d'un d'infections
sexuellement transmissibles par
sécrétion par sécrétions génitales et du
coup est ce qu'il ya une prévention sur
spécifique parce qu'on n'a pas parlé de
rapports sexuels protégés des choses
comme ça sur les publics dont on dit
qu'ils sont plus spécifiquement atteint
possible mais l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup merci pour cet exposé je
suis désolé de revenir avec la même
question qui va un peu vous embêter mais
j'avoue que moi aussi j'ai du mal à
comprendre l'utilisation d'arguments du
secret défense parce qu'on en fait on
vous pose pas la question de savoir
combien il ya de vaccins en stock pour
nous protéger d'une éventuelle attaque
biologique dans le cadre qui mettrait en
péril la sécurité nationale j'espère
d'ailleurs fait je ne sais pas mais
enfin que ces stocks las de toute façon
seront préservés et que ce qu'on utilise
pour vacciner la population générale qui
est
potentiellement
sujette à aux infections ne réduit pas
notre capacité à nous défendre quand on
regarde donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué pour nous je ne comprends pas
ce mot et nous expliquer pourquoi le
secret défense s'appliquerait à des
stocks de vaccins qui ne sont pas qu'ils
n'ont pas vocation à être utilisé dans
le cadre d'une d'une attaque sur notre
sécurité nationale
ensuite si vous voulez quand même pas
nous répondre sur combien on a deux
vaccins jeu s'est posé la question
différemment est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire combien de doses sont prévues
pour être des stockés dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent on a une petite
indication du dit 120000 donc ça c'est
si j'ai bien compris les zones
voilà si les hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec les hommes et sous prête je
crois que ça comme ça c'est exclu les
travailleurs du sexe etc j'imagine ce
donc un petit peu au dessus de ça le
public cible
parce que la question suivante c'est
les remontées terrain qu'on a en fait on
vous poserai pas cette question sur les
stocks s'ils en gohelle et remontée de
terrain qu'on avait c'était ben en fait
tout va bien les gens qui ont besoin de
se faire vacciner arrive à avoir un
rendez vous pour ce faire vacciner on se
pose la question parce que les remontées
qu'on a c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
rendez-vous disponible donc dr yves a
été activée je prends la frontière bon
ben on une demi journée il y avait pas
il ya plus de rendez-vous disponibles il
ya des régions disent qu'il n'y a pas du
tout centre qui apparaissent et donc la
question c'est pas du coup c'est quoi le
problème si c'est pas une question de
stock qu'est ce qui explique en fait que
compte que les rendez-vous sont pas
disponibles et à quel terme on peut
résoudre le problème
la raison pour laquelle on est à
l'inquiétude sur les stoks et qu'on
comprend pas trop c'est que là je me
trompe peut-être mais l'union européenne
à une semble organisé un achat groupé de
vaccins
la france a décidé de ne pas faire
partie de cet achat groupé
pourquoi et quelle est la raison et et
est-ce que ça a un rapport avec le fait
qu'on est en difficulté aujourd'hui pour
assurer les vaccinations
[Musique]
l'autre question c'est est sûre est ce
que vous pourriez médicalement nous dire
les personnes qui ont été vaccinées pour
la variole avant qu'on arrête donc en
1984 le
ce que vous estimez être leur niveau de
protection par rapport à la période du
singe
ensuite j'ai une question sur les
surveiller sur les protocoles de
d'isolement donc les personnes qui ont
été infectées qui sont hospitalisés qui
sont donc si j'ai bien compris en
isolement on a quand même des retours
des personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
qu'ils n'ont pas suivi
comme il faudrait ou qui est pas qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'informations sur ce
qu'elles doivent faire pendant la
période d'isolement comment vous gérez
le contact avec les patients qui sont en
isolement mais non hospitalisés et la
dernière question plutôt prendre
gouvernement c'est effectivement en a on
a une maladie qui n'est pas et c'est
bien le rappeler à proprement parler
sexuellement transmissibles dans son sol
elle n'est pas transmissible par les par
le sperme mais elle touche pour tout un
tas de raisons aujourd'hui une
communauté en particulier
moi je suis un peu inquiète différents
violences discriminations qui peuvent
être générées par ça on a vu au début de
l'épidémie du co lead qui avait des
personnes
identifiées comme chinoise qui se
faisaient agresser dans le métro dans la
rue est ce que au delà de la de la
communication en termes de prévention
médicale vous pensez aussi à une
communication
sur ce sujet là pour éviter qu'on ait
des violences et des attaques envers les
communautés cibles merci merci alors
qu'ils commencent
monsieur coignard dont l'inde était
passé à ses concerts je peux répondre
sur la question
sur s unit est effectivement
cette question d'être importante a
répondu à plusieurs définitions de vie
et c'était une infection sexuellement
transmissible
stricto sensu c'est une infection qui
est lié à un agent pathogène qui a été
retrouvé dans les sécrétions génitales
aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet est
effectivement bien évidemment de travaux
il ya quelques publications qui font
état de présence d' adn viral dans le
sperme mais est ce que il s'agit d'un
virus infectieux ça reste à prouver donc
aujourd'hui on a pas d'évidence pour
appliquer cette définition donc au sens
strict aux sangsues aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas dire que c'est une ist après il
ya une définition plus large de l'om
est-ce d'heuliez astier qui est celle de
toute infection qui se transmet lors de
rapports sexuels non protégés
la notion de rapport non protégé doit
ici être comprise comme non protégé par
un préservatif externe ou interne donc
là aussi c'est cesser il faut faire
attention parce que si on qualifie le
monkey pox d'y rester on va laisser
penser éventuellement à certaines
parties de la population que porter un
préservatif entre tech qui n'est pas le
cas puisqu'on l'a rappelé c'est une
infection qui se transmet principalement
par des contacts directs de poids peau
en contact avec un patient qu'il ya des
lésions
voilà donc c'est pas non plus une
nouveau je rappelle qu'on a eu il ya
quelques années des épidémies d'e comme
hermès ont pas fait on a eu il ya
quelques années aussi d épidémie
d'hépatite à ou de chic elle ose dans
des communautés homosexuelles masculines
et c'était des modes de transmission
aussi de pathogènes non étiquetés y
rester mais qui survenait dans le cadre
de rapports sexuels donc aujourd'hui
ni le cd sénile oms ne considère ni les
cdc aux états unis ne considèrent
l'infection à ne manquer pas comme une
ist mais par contre on est tous d'accord
sur le fait qu'elle peut se transmettent
durant des contacts intimes entre
personnes et c'est vrai qu'à ce titre ce
n'est pas et clément d'un service allait
rappeler une maladie qui se limite qui
est spécifique de la communauté
homosexuelle masculine
aujourd'hui c'est la principale
populations à risque mais comme je le
dis on reste très vigilant sur la
détection de cas qui se transmettrait
dans les mêmes circonstances mais dans
d'autres populations donc pour répondre
aussi à la question est ce qu'on est sur
une endémie une épidémie on est
clairement aujourd'hui sur une épidémie
qui se concentrent principalement dans
une communauté
homosexuelle masculine avec de rares
cajoler rappelé un café mines 1 et 2 cas
pédiatriques qui sortent un peu de ce
profil
mais je crois que j'ai répondu aux
questions que j'avais repéré mais je
suis prêt à compléter si besoin non
monsieur lazarus sur le secret défense
dites nous tout alors je vais vous dire
sur le secret défense
donc sur le secret défense
je voulais dit ce stock de vaccin
antivariolique
il a été constituée dans le cadre du
plan variole jeu le plan variole il est
piloté par le secrétariat général de la
défense et la sécurité nationale est
donc le secret lui appartient le secret
lui à partir si je vous dis vu les
choses qui sont couverts par le secret
je risque cinq ans de prison et 100
mille euros d'amande
je vous trouve très pousse au crime mais
voilà j'essaye de tenir bon
et
les vaccins qui sont dans ce stock je
rentre pas dans le détail pour les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer mais en
cédant des sondés vaccin contre la
variole et qu'on peut utiliser pour le
vaccin de troisième génération pour le
mans qui boxe et donc c'est ça qu'on est
en train de faire c'est qu'on les
utilise dans une autre indication que
celle du stock à ce stade le stock est
toujours que couverts par le secret et
et ça perdure on verra si nous on n'a
pas d'intérêt particulier à ce que c'est
ça le soir je le dis clairement ce qui
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'on
livre sur le terrain et ce qu'on prévoit
d'approvisionner ce que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui je vous ai dit quelques
milliers de doses qui sont déjà assurés
sur le terrain et d'autre quelques
milliers qui sont en cours je peux
préciser un peu les choses on a déjà à
déstocker 7500 dose et on a cinq mille
doses qui sont déjà prévues pour la
semaine prochaine et cela dès la semaine
suivante et on continuera comme ça en
fonction des besoins des ars qui est qui
nous sont remontés et on organise le
schéma logistique avec santé publique
france et avec au fur et à mesure des
ouvertures de centres de vaccination
c'est pas le seul facteur qui pourrait
être limitant je pense pas dire que ça
le soit puisqu'on libre en fonction des
besoins et ça peut prendre un peu de
temps vous monsieur
vous me ferez grâce à vos questions mais
bon sur les parce qu'on est aussi la
semaine du 14 juillet est donc même avec
la meilleure volonté des services de
l'état et avec ces opérateurs s'est pas
complètement tribales comme contrainte
et donc on continuer à y travailler et
puis aussi toutes les contraintes de
terrain alors qu'il faut avoir les bras
pour vacciner les organisations et ça
nécessite du monde des ressources
humaines est d'avis qu'il connaît bien
ces contraintes pour elle pourra vous en
parler c'est aussi ça la vraie vie et la
réalité du temps donc on essaye de fait
de monter en charge tous collectivement
pour pouvoir offrir avoir une offre de
vaccination qui soit satisfaisante qui
permette que les gens qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner le soir on continuera à
le faire et on va suivre les choses et
c'est bien le but tif
sur les commandes joue les dix il ya eu
il y avait déjà des stocks qui était
présente dès le début l'alertent on a
refait des commandes il y à une
livraison qui est arrivé il ya d'autres
livraisons qui l'ont programmé et il ya
des commandes qui sont à l'étude donc on
continue c'est silvia leu sur la
question du de la commande européenne
merci
danser dans une cadre de cette commande
la priorité est donnée à des pays qui
n'ont pas de stocks nous on a un stock
et donc l'idée est plutôt des solidaires
avec nos collègues européens et que ceux
qui le souhaitent puissent commander des
stocks et donc c'est comme ça que quand
on agit on insulte pas l'avenir de dire
que dans le futur on essaye d'être
pragmatique et d'agir dans un cadre
européen
coordonné
sur les antécédents de vaccination
variole bayal yarn avis de la haute
autorité de santé effectivement ils ont
besoin que d'une seule dose qui indique
bien que il ya un niveau de protection
qui qui préexiste évidemment plus
l'ancienneté du vaccin est importante -
le niveau de protection et les formes
mais je laisserai mes collègues précisé
et sur l'isolément oui sur les personnes
qui ont vraiment besoin d'un
accompagnement à l'isolément il peut
arriver qu'il y ait des hospitalisations
pour accompagnement à l isolement qui
soit faite lescure pour à vous d'en
parler les ars quand elles le peuvent et
quand elles en ont connaissance d'un cas
qui a mal on a du mal à s'isoler peuvent
les accompagner a appelé plusieurs fois
dans la semaine et ses devoirs et avoir
une action pragmatique
et il faut qu'on continue l isolement a
fortiori sur une période aussi longue de
21 jours c'est pas c'est pas simple et
on le prend en compte aussi
il faut qu'on continue à y travailler ça
je suis tout à fait d'accord
et le labo j'ai en fait je suis en train
de poser la question et le labo
s'appelle bavaria nordiques
et je suis en train de poser la question
de savoir me répond c'est un labo danois
avec des filiales en allemagne en suisse
et aux etats unis
mais j'avoue que je sais c'est sur la
question donc j'ai fait un appel à mes
collègues
ah oui ce sont des multidoses l'heure
c'est en monodose unitaire
alors il ya des conditions de
température pour la conservation et le
transport qui n'est que ce sujet et a
complètement simple parce que c'est du
moins 80 en stockage et moi et moins 20
en transport on peut pas s'abstraire des
aspects du fabricant on regarde de
manière très rapprochée avec santé but
france avec le msm toutes les marges de
facilitation qu'on peut se donner mais
mais c'est pas complètement simple on a
aussi l'expérience du duke au vide sur
le moins 80 qui et qui nous aide un
petit peu
qu'ils continuent vous souhaitez
prolonger un petit peu et puis ensuite
foncé sur les ce que pour terminer oui
moi je voulais donner quelques éléments
sur la question de la discrimination de
la population lgbt ça c'est quelque
chose auquel on a été extrêmement
sensible dès le début et on est en
travail très en lien le dr lazarus a
rappelé tout à l'heure avec les des
associations lgbt on travaille avec eux
depuis longtemps on travaille sur le
terrain avec eux c'est eux qui diffuse
nos nos flyers et je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure il considère aussi que c'est
excessif est une référence et donc le
choix qu'on a fait en matière de
communication c'est de cibler cette
population là mais on vraiment en termes
de cible comme en marketing et en
revanche djamel évoqué pour essayer de
limiter au maximum les amalgames et plus
largement sur la question de la
discrimination
on est dans une démarche à santé
publique france 2 d'essayer de faire
évoluer dans le bon sens les les
représentations de l'ensemble de la
population sur ces questions en
particulier sur les populations lgbt
pour terminer professeur lescure pour
compléter des points et des réponses
courtes la première sur les centres de
vaccination
aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé clairement
lazarus il ya des centres qui sont
référencés mais c'est vrai que pour tout
vous dire certains ne sont pas encore
activé et comme le disait et clément on
est dans une période compliquée pour
actionner des activités nouvelles et je
pense que malgré tout tout le monde fait
preuve de bonne volonté dans le contexte
mais c'est vrai que premièrement il ya
du monde qui du monde au portillon entre
guillemets et donc on a des beaucoup de
déceptions en termes de des attentes et
on a des rendez vous qui sont beaucoup
trop loin par rapport à des as
en était que les gens aimeraient plus
festif et moins contraints
pour résumer les affaires et
deuxièmement on a beaucoup de
difficultés sur le terrain à prioriser
le post exposition par rapport à la pré
exposition notamment par exemple sur des
prises de rendez-vous d'octo libre etc
et donc il ya des difficultés
opérationnelles qui qui qui qui sont
toujours présentes deuxième point sur la
question des ist je reviendrai pas sur
la définition très précise
du docteur
bruno coignard pardon ce qui est clair
c'est que et comme le disait clément
lazarus
aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes les
preuves mais on a un certain nombre
d'éléments dans un faisceau qui
probablement concours à
considérer de façon pragmatique que on
peut concerner peut parler d'y rester de
façon pragmatique
les anglais recommande le port du
préservatif jusqu'à huit semaines après
le virus a été détecté dans les liquides
biologiques notamment liquide séminal et
le sperme
pour les virologues on a un virus
extrêmement solide et donc quand on
trouve ce virus on considère et les
virologues considère qu'il est infecté
et on a une sémiologie au niveau génital
et au niveau des muqueuses qui semble
évoquer a vraiment une transmission par
le rapport sexuel au delà des contacts
répétés intime haut niveau au niveau
cutané
[Musique]